Hey Peter, how's it going? Hey sarge,
how are you doing? Pretty good.
Can I ask you 67 questions?
You sure.
What is the culture like at UC Berkeley?
Very supportive. Uh,
hardworking but fun culture.
Will online learning replaced
physical learning? Well,
um, I think it started to shift a lot
in that direction, but I personally,
the real luck to meet the
people I'm learning from.
What is something you miss
about where you grew up? Um,
I'd say the food. The food? Yeah.
What time do you wake up? Um,
it 20. What website do you
absolutely love to spend time on?
Um,
let's see.
I try to avoid spending too
much time on any websites.
Machine learning paper of 2017.
Um, I'm going to pass on
that. It seems too, too,
too picky to meet one person. Who
would it be? Okay. I need one person.
Who could it be? Um, Roger Federer.
Favorite car? Uh, I prefer my bike.
What's it like working
with physical robots?
It's been really surprising how people
connect so strongly when they see
physical robots do things.
I never anticipated this.
When bringing people buy for
the first time in the lab,
bravest thing you've ever done?
I'm not the one to take a lot of risks.
I would say. What is one
thing that scares you? Um,
I like to take good care of my
health, I guess. Favorite movie,
Shawshank redemption. Do you
play any instruments? No.
What's more interesting?
Physics or neuroscience
call. But uh, I'm at, I've been more
inclined to study physics so far.
Best present you've ever received.
What is something you do to relax?
A lot of physical exercise, running
tennis, basketball, cycling.
What is something surprising about you
beat that? Uh, back in high
school, my, uh, well my goal was,
was tried to become a
professional basketball player
rather than a researcher.
You prefer cats or dogs?
I prefer a no pets in my house.
Why do you like reinforcement
learning specifically? So much
beauty of reinforcement learning is
that it kind of gets to what is kind of
close to what you think about when
you build a real intelligence system.
It's something that has,
tries to achieve goals,
try to learn things about the
environments. Never done before.
And I find that very intriguing.
Favorite project you used to work on?
I would say Stanford helicopter
project as a phd student and I
think a live, it was the big pants we
went through to get to the results, um,
which made it yet more
rewarding too to get to them.
What project are you currently working on?
A lot of our work is,
so there's a few things
going on at Berkeley.
A lot of the work is on
reinforcement learning, imitation,
learning metal learning.
I'd embodied intelligence with trying
to put this into practice and get real
robots in the real world to do these
things. And then I have great scope.
We're trying to do it now.
Ai for grading automatically grade
your homework and exams are largely
automatically grade them to uh,
let teachers spend time on other things.
If you could repeat one experience again,
what would it be?
Speed one experience again.
What would it be?
I'll pass on that for now.
Why do you think deep learning
has gotten so popular recently?
I think it's,
it's getting really good results on
problems that people just weren't able to
get the same results on. Think
computer vision, speech recognition,
learning to peer that play video games,
learning to control robots, prompts.
I seemed out of reach for a very long
time and now there's a real tangible
progress.
What's your favorite operating
system? Macro s for me.
Do you play any sports?
Um, they'll play it. I tried to
play a lot of sports. My favorite ones
are tennis, basketball and a running.
What one source you use to stay
up to date in machine learning?
Um, definitely archive
is uh, critical. Uh,
and then newsfeeds, like her
party's archive, sanity preserver.
And also on Twitter. I follow a lot of
people that poster papers on Twitter.
What's one? And they'll research or
you fall in Twitter? Just a random one.
Jeff Dean programming.
Language of choice for machine.
I should admit that as a professor
I don't write a lot of code. Um,
so it's mostly my students who,
who write the code.
So I don't really have a preference here.
Favorite professor? Harris professor? No,
I'll go with my phd advisor. Android.
Why do you think programming is fun?
You think programming is fun because in
a very short amount of time you can do
very powerful things compared to any
other engineering discipline where
typically it takes days, weeks, months
to build something and programming.
You can build something in an
hour that actually does something.
Last person you talked to on the phone?
I'm
not sure. Yeah. You get an all
expenses paid trip to one country.
Where do you go?
Australia.
Would you live on Mars?
It depends on who comes along with me.
What's one thing you can't live without?
Exercise.
What is one skill you wished you had?
Have time to polish more programming
skills which have not finding time for
anymore. What is the law? What is
usually the last thing you do before bed?
I do a few dedicated stretches
and breathing exercises
that get me into sleeping
mode.
What texts editor do you use?
I use sublime.
Sublime.
What open source library
do you really like?
Okay.
Personally,
don't use them myself,
but I know my group benefits a
lot from tensorflow and Pi Torch.
What was a hard problem
your team recently solved?
MMM,
super. Recently. Those
results are not public yet,
but there'll be a couple of
papers coming out that it will be,
I'm very excited about of
things that are already public.
I would say the one shot visual limitation
where work led by Chelsea Finn where
we're able to learn from videos of
humans showing how to do something rather
than from tell operating robots
and the robot can learn from that.
What's the goal for embodied.ai?
Our goal is our longterm goal is
essentially make physical goods as readily
available and as cheaply available as
digital goods by making manufacturing and
logistics extremely,
extremely streamlined, best
advice you've ever received.
Um,
let's see.
Maybe I wouldn't say explicit advice,
but I think maybe what our hold
the closest to my heart as a,
what I've seen from being
Andrex phd students is, um,
how kindness is always in everything
he's doing and how, you know,
that is just a really important
value and no matter, you know,
what you're trying to achieve.
What's one piece of advice you'd
give yourself 20 years ago?
Um,
that's all
pretty happy with how things have gone.
I don't think I would give myself any
other advice and that I think not,
I'm not saying I went down the
shortest path and everything,
but I think sometimes going down a path
that ends and having to restart is not
about thing you spend more time
on the internet is or real life.
I spend most of my time
I'm behind the computer,
uh, and as a way to essentially
communicate about research
with my collaborators.
What's something you've
learned in the past month?
MMM,
I would
say what I've heard in the last month is
that I have not found any time to read
any papers in. I need to change
that. If you ran the world,
what is one light you didn't
enact immediately? If it
worked? The rule the world?
Is that what you said? Wow.
What a hypothetical. Um,
I think it's really complicated too to put
things in place. But I think, you know,
if just in general people,
if we could somehow find a way for people
to be more kind of just generally kind
and everything they do,
I think a lot of problems would be
resolved in the singularity near
not sure what's near, but uh, I guess
given we started embodied intelligence,
we think there is still,
you know,
a lot to be done with regular AI
before the singularity will take over.
If you were to start from scratch today,
what is he learning resource you
would use to learn machine learning?
Yeah, so it's a couple of
things I would use. I would um,
look had the faster they
AI to learn a few things.
From there I would look had Andrew Rinks,
uh,
deep learning AI course.
I would look at [inaudible] d planning
course and then I would look at the
deeper El bootcamp that we built last
summer and also surrogate Levin's deep
reinforced planning course.
And all of those are available on line
so anybody can start working with those
favorite subject in school.
When you were growing up cause x,
if you could be a superhero,
who would it be?
Yeah,
I guess I,
in fact if I could be a superhero,
I'm not too familiar
with most superhero sell.
Maybe I'll pick a real world person and
I'd like to be somebody who really mix a
lot of difference.
So I think the way Elon Musk is tackling
things like climate change bottom up by
building companies that can really make
a change. I find that really inspiring.
What's your spirit animal?
A Koala?
What do you predict comes next
after the deep learning hype?
Okay.
I think what we've seen with deep learning
is at the essence leverage the things
that are today available that you didn't
have before. More data, more compute.
And so I see a trend where we'll continue
to have more data and more compute.
So if anything comes about
that can leverage even better,
more data, more compute,
maybe metal learning if you consider
it separate from deep learning.
But I think it's part of it.
But anything that really leveraged to
the latest resources that are available.
But more questions, coffee or
tea, tea, summer or winter,
summer,
Google home or Amazon Alexa.
I always switch both of
them off chrome or safari,
chrome, WWDC or Google. Io.
None of them are are the rights or
rights for me, nips and I clear. Awesome.
All right, Peter, that's it
for my questions. Thanks so
much for answering those.
Sure. Thanks, Sarah. Have a good one.